the Joe Rogan experience the thing is
about striking too is like striking when
you mix in with wrestling you can kind
of get away with a lot more a lot more
crazy [ __ ] happens people knock people
out that maybe wouldn't knock people out
normally like Kevin Randleman was an
amazing example that he knocked out
Mirko Cro Cop at the left hook that yeah
now if they were in a straight kick
boxing match it's definitely possible
that Kevin could do that kevin was an
incredible athlete
but you had favored heavily that Mirko
would be able to stuff that all day all
day most likely because he was so elite
in that realm but you add striking to
MMA and you know there's like there's so
much craziness going on that sometimes
it's hard for people to clearly
establish like who's actually better on
their feet until someone can stop the
craziness there's a third Lions yeah and
then you get to this level there's this
level we get like a monster doll he's a
perfect example cuz he's so goddamn good
he's so smart he's so technical and he
finds these openings that maybe other
people don't see
or maybe they can't get to where those
openings are and he finds those so you
think you're doing good you think you're
doing good but he's waiting he's waiting
for the moment where he sees this spot
that he's been looking at and boom he
cracks tear until with that step in left
hook and puts him out you got a [ __ ]
animal like Darren till you're no cold
come on I think John's one of those guys
too like we kind of because of his last
few opponent there was like God maybe
he's older he's lost a step and I watch
and I go oh he's playing with his food
he's playing with his food it's not I'm
not disrespecting those guys who he's
father Dominick graves who he's gonna
fight but for Johnny look at his leg you
see in the legends that he's fought it's
tough for him to get up for the
challenge so he's playing with his food
right now wait till he fights
I'm telling you wait till he goes to
heavy weight you're gonna see the old
John when he 20 when there's actual
where he thinks it's a challenge wait
till you see him fight a steep AR
Francis you're gonna see the monster
come out right now he's just picking
with his food yeah I'll do that
all right yeah let's do it I think I
think he's in cruise control I think
you're entirely correct and I think when
you are at that Elita level when you've
never been defeated you have one loss
it's a [ __ ] loss everybody knows -
[ __ ] loss he really should get his
record clean let's meet something do you
mean they cleared him with this hope
gram [ __ ] they found out that this is we
just have this new ability to measure
substances in the most miniscule amounts
that it's so ridiculous that just some
random sort of vitamin that has some
contaminant when one millionth of a
[ __ ] gram or whatever the others dick
pan or protein all the friends [ __ ] test
positive that's not a drug it's not like
so much cheating it's just so they
cleared him on that right you saw it it
makes this whole statement about the the
new way they're viewing this stuff
because the fact their equipments just
amazing you can't hide from shout out to
you side of them I like that you silent
yeah it's so good you guys are flagging
yes we're gonna back off yeah
and they learn from it I love it I love
that they did the same with marijuana
they realize like we're not dealing with
in a performance enhancer so all these
guys aren't fighting hi this is just
like how helping them sleep and relax
not hurt it's not helping anybody in
terms it's like not making them stronger
or faster so and it might help them with
anxiety and a lot of other things so
they released that right they're doing
good things but with John it's cleared
that he wasn't taking anything this is
just some some [ __ ] that's a residual
like a residue that's on something else
some contaminated supplement same thing
would happen with Tim means to means God
bust the same way they mean they dragged
it out with him for months a lot of guys
when he was at its peak really I know
when he was peaking in the UFC and he's
won one of the most interesting
welterweights all the sudden boom he
gets a suspension from tainted
supplements you look at the guy he's not
a [ __ ] steroid how about Tom Waller
yes this is career Josh Barnett
I know same thing people are upset a few
you sorry like we don't like we're
trying to move forward and get better
right it sucks for those guys and I feel
so terrible for those guys review solid
like our bat we learn though man there's
nothing the thing is you sada has a long
career you know when you got a guy like
Tim means or a guy like Josh Burnett
there's a window well josh has had an
extremely long window obviously
youngest-ever UFC heavyweight champion
the longest yeah but that extremely long
window I mean it's gonna come to a close
and they took away a large chunk of it
for something turned out to not be
accurate but they're gonna last a long
time with these guys like they say that
like at their peak the best fighters
have nine years at their peak
that's a long time it's a long time the
only guys really hit that nine years
stride at peak form I think it's like
Anderson phaidor there's like a few like
real legends GSP obviously GSP jon-jon
obviously right John is undefeated right
now I mean they took his title away wins
it back rides never it never lost a
title fight and you're dealing with the
guy wins the title youngest ever in the
sport flying knee opener on Shogun had
just nothing but success since then
people are like inspecting him with a
micro spokes expecting him to fall off
like you're dealing with the goat it's
hilarious
he's the goat and he went after the
Santos fire my common sense was at one
leg so I went back and watched John
Jones fight and you watch you're like oh
he's in he can and give two [ __ ] about
being in the right now well he was smart
too because he's smart he's it's
dangerous but at the same time he could
have took him down his coaches like dude
talking his manager like we were like
dude take him down he's like now I'm
saying this but he won it's hard for him
to to because you look at the resume of
guys he's beat and then they're like
again it's not a knock on Tom ik race
now I'm not gone Corey Anderson or
Anthony Smith but you're like here's
Anthony Smith and John's like all right
you know let's do it man so it you know
that's he's [ __ ] with his food right
now well he's so good but he's still
able to fight out like the Gustafson
fight the early one the first one was a
perfect example of him falling into a
trap right partying too hard didn't
train train for two weeks or barely
right everyone campus like they were
like saying what what do we do here he
goes out and guts it out wins in the
stretch wins down the stretch like he
had to be pushed went down the stretch
right then I trained with Dustin for
that fight and I'm talking the best I've
ever seen in the training room as I
imagine oh this guy's never gonna lose
yeah oh he's the best I've ever seen he
would spar five rounds with me didn't
jump in with a heavyweight professional
boxer and [ __ ] him up
five five five five pound beat the [ __ ]
out of me and I'm like what he's never
gonna lose John didn't you not
understand didn't train didn't dream
what the distance and one down the
stretch
one down stretch gutted it out dot and
Gus fans the best light heavyweight of
all time if he was in a different air
and there's no DC or John Jones he's
there go but you can't say that's how
good yes he's but don't if those two
[ __ ] guys aren't there yeah you moves
right close to being the right good with
the first fight
yes but then the second fight John just
runs him over because John took it
serious very seriously I wanted to prove
oh he's good
check this out yeah how about the DC
fight all right Beach indecision that's
cool run it back boom okay a head kick
yeah and not just a head kick but head
kick on the side where DC said you're
not going to trick me into leaning
towards my right well you can hit me
with that left kick like they actually
had a conversation about it
[Applause]